hello everyone my name is Selena freon I
am a senior scientist in the Department
of Pathology at Stanford University
today I will give you a brief overview
on how to reveal the tumor in your
biology using an imaging technology
called multiplex
ion beam imaging by Thomas light or
negative
the first aim of our webinar is focused
on how the new ethos is used in cancer
research where I will show you how the
summative technology is applicable to a
variety of healthy and new plastic
tissue and what is the outcome that it
will be able to achieve the second aim
is focused on learning how to design and
optimize the middle panel for cancer
research so they 3d technology is an
innovative system which utilizes a
continuous primary light source with
orthogonal time of flight mass
spectrometry to imaging antibodies that
will make a reporters a subcellular
resolution of the formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded mm tissue as you can
see from this figure there are four main
instrument components the sample stage
where they slide with tissue uploaded
the primary ion source encoding for
sputtering the specimen with primary
items the electrostatic analyzer which
filters secondary ions with respect to
kinetic energy and finally the
orthogonal acceleration time applies
mass spectrometer which analyzes the
quantity of isotope bound position
so today's a brief overview how this
technology works
we have depicted on the right figure the
primary items that are hitting the
Kishin
in these are the iron the denials
released by the primary ion source once
the primary ensures the primary iron
being sputtered the elemental reporter
and tissue endogenous element secondary
ions are released from the tissue here
we have two types of secondary Islands
we have monotonic and polyatomic aliens
and without monotonic and polar
traumatization monatomic ions are
elemental ions or single atoms with high
energy which move faster we are the one
that goes to the top where they get
sorted by this mask and they heat the
detector while polyatomic ions are
molecular Islands clustered together
with low energy which moves slower
basically they are those ion that gets
back and do not reach the top because of
their low energy so to be more specific
they are stuff that comes out from a
tissue cancer button which covalent bond
has not been broken for example because
no much energy has been transferred to
them anything that has not been
completely ionized or maybe awesome that
maked act with organic material such as
carbon hydrogen oxygen or molecular
conglomerate's exception so the question
is how does the filter is done I won't
go through all the details but basically
there is an energy filtering played by
the electrostatic analyzer where the gap
is chosen to maximize the signal to
noise by gas I mean the key to where the
signal and noise emotions appear so the
idea is to break all the covalent bond
and help on atomic ions going through
the detector moving forward these
monatomic ions enter the orthogonal
time-of-flight mass analyzer which
analyzes the quantity of either the
bound to itself the aisles are then
separated based on their masses and our
accelerate to the detector finally the
detector measures the computer which
Isaac
for each bloom the next point to show a
how we beat off can seriously quantify
all naturally occurring element from
hydrogen to uranium we use these
capabilities to simultaneously provide
the subcellular expression and
localization of up to 42 elementally
labeled antibody as well as native
biological elements such as phosphate
and iron we additionally as you can see
on the next figure we additionally
ensure that we detox is designed to
support the large field of view with no
knowledge as you can see in this figure
on the Left which we call surveys can
usually land at low resolution to
capture for example is to more
availability and also
on the next set of image on the right it
allows for a quick scan of a single
section for example specific region of
interest identified Universal village
camp in this context region 2 6 & 7 of
breast cancer tissue enable study design
at different scales of computing
resolution or even acquisition of
multiplex 3-dimensional energy the next
slide is to show in showing the
acquisition time in need and the
resolution should achieve for the 20
micron square field as you can see from
the diagram low resolution 1 micron take
only one second to be scan while highly
resolution 1 the sitting on nature take
approximately one hour
therefore as as reporting on the right
figure we can perceive the surveys can
follow by a rescan of the same field of
view on high resolution to unveil
further details for example subcellular
localizations certain targets like lemon
and double strand DNA in this example i
would like also to arrive at currently
the next generation I ensured
commercially available is capable to
provide much brighter images 4 to 5
times faster limited in approximately 18
minutes you can have a 400 micron square
image scan on high resolution
to the next slide
we can see that recording to implement
really on different biological tissue
like leader placenta long after and
lower GI BreastScreen link followed skin
tones II and also in brain in order to
characterize the host immune responses
living and around the tumor
microenvironment with a particular focus
on the stimulatory and auditory image
checkpoint molecules in various litem we
currently work with both as I feel as
well as frozen tissue mainly from humans
monkeys and mice
some example on how our lab has
implemented medical technology in the
field of cancer inflammation and
infection be really much like a diamond
dispersed light into its individual
riddles
this technology allows us to separate
the most specifically evaluated to the
different feature underlying the state
of tissue in the multitude of abilities
therefore identifying the Leukemia and
mesenchymal component immune cells
vascularization tumor specific target
functional molecules and transcription
factors and what type of information are
you able to circulate what other types
using this method we are able to
extrapolate from a single biopsies not
on information for forty two targets
analyzed simultaneously but also their
localization and spatial and regions
around and live in atomic environment so
as you can see from this figure we are
currently working on several cancer type
the big tip is looks like triple breast
negative cancer glioblastoma several
carcinomas in large tankers bladder and
kidney melanoma in breast carcinoma we
are also actively working in ad
inflammatory and infectious diseases
like a diner pulmonary hypertension
preeclampsia and micro bacterial
tuberculosis on the back of this
dialogue which are depicted in red you
can see how we implemented in the top
four new monetary clinical trial in
cancer and ocean the CA with cancer
treatment activities for which I can
show you right now an example
this is a recently submitted publication
in collaboration with Lucilla where we
reported implementation of the music
technology to biopsy hope from a patient
which developed treatment toxicity the
patient was found to have colorectal
carcinoma as well as individual personal
after receiving combination of genetics
in brachytherapy treatment to divide
biopsies show a metastatic lymph node
the patient sought consultation Lucilla
receiving treatment for pneumonia mark
and achieving complete response at 17
months however after 32 months of
therapy renewal map the patient
developed severe gastric pain and nausea
and anorexia on these four represents
the image is selected the biopsy from
the gastric antral and body shows
similar features which were
characterized by machines eroding
Nicosia
the Crypt angel and dropout associated
in trachea and lamina propria mix
inflammation that included frequent
lymphocyte and Matrixyl we therefore
analyzed the gastric special using a new
panel comprising target for T cells B
cells regulatory t-cells and K and my
lord components we also introduced
targets to identify the known inner
compartment such as endothelial cells
using chiral and epithelial cells and
finally 50 functional targets and you
can see on this image we hope to
introduce all the necessary tissue
control to ensure the target sensitivity
and specificity here we present the case
of Ebola map associated alternative
striping to explain a possible role of
the main cell type of handlers in the
dramatically responds with selective 13
presentative regenerated from the a
china seen on the last of the gastro
biopsy
and a disco cause we leverage the
ability of widget us to identify the
presence and proportion of infiltrating
yourself from a single section of biopsy
specimen our analysis revealed a
gastrula characterized by significant in
infiltration note' primarily in the
lamina propria mainly composed of
t-cells and to elect flexor stand by
macrophages and Marcel's sparse be
served and dendritic cells and NK cells
were also noted in the lamina propria
in addition we found moderate levels of
c31 cells in the lamina propria
highlighting a significant degree of
regularity across the gastric mucosa on
the other hand epithelial cells I'd like
to be yellow on the first in your on the
left displayed consistently elevate
interferon gamma expression throughout
the region which may be a potential
contributor to the shape to the obscure
gastritis
the majority of Pizza we're see before
and this press CD 4500 and each Olivia
and pigeons we also observe Fox
leapreader the lithography cell finished
consistent within parameters phenotype
observed here on the other hand the
majority of cd8 t-cells lacked grams I
mean while the macrophage infiltrated
areas surrounded gastric patina lacked h
labia and interferon gamma quantitative
analysis perform on all the reader
further corroborate that 345 positive
cells as you can see on the diagram
below represent approximately 40 percent
of the cells found in the gastric tissue
followed by mesenchymal epithelium in
the nuclear yourself
in addition
jority of being in ourselves
approximately 70% we're feeling for side
followed by macrophages and mast cells
while the remaining units offset each
accounted for less than 5% so taken
together the stricken feature in this
case study of bb10 business tracking
include lamina propria
extension by mononuclear inflammation
characterized by cd4 and cd8 t-cell
infiltrate lacking early reduces
pressure of browning diabetes in socks
to treat respectively
if you kill an angel from crypt of
mitosis intricate alien lymphocytic and
neutrophilic inflammation as well as
expression of interferon gamma by
epithelial cells to conclude we were
able to investigate certain feature via
midi dolls which highlighted the need of
additional investigation to increase the
understanding of the regulation of
inflammation and epicly some changes in
the upper gastrointestinal tract of
ability one therapy the next slide
briefly highlight a work in progress in
collaboration with the RAB knowledge
level here at Stanford University where
we aim to provide them basic cell
population in pulmonary hypertension
patients biopsy then ELISA validation
was carry out on human SS beautician
well representative to millimeter Corps
of tonsil sling nympho no GI placenta
normal lank and diseased lung tissue
were compiled into a tissue microwave to
optimize and validate validate the
proposed 38 market panel the patient
code and tissue control we're staying
here and it will analyze by moody Tov
the final testing and evaluated on the
same team name by cineplex iota see
where the antibody that show expected
results across different tissue by us
the chemistry where compared to the
negative expression pattern in
combination with visual comparison of
market graduation and the last example
is another working progress in
glioblastoma multiforme which started as
an internal project and as recently
being co-founded by partner Institute
for counseling therapy and the Cancer
Research Institute the overall aim of
our project is to occur it determine the
infiltrating and resident my large cell
type and state in glioblastoma biopsy
and to match special results cellular
networks we want to understand how cells
are communication changes the
information processing and ultimately
affect tumor development and treatment
to this end we are using these novel
experimental and computational
approaches that allow for highly
multiplex spatially result comprehension
single cells naturality of cells in
Berga tissue using our medical
technology we will be able to invade the
role of glioma infiltrating macrophages
individuality
more specifically we hope to elucidate
which cell phenotype can produce patient
survival and response to treatment how
they live and where they are locating
lady the brain micro environment these
hopefully will give as insightful
featuring a therapy strategy in
beardless coma and here below is simply
display how about how midi validation
has been carry out for this project
where appropriate issue control like
tonsils being placenta liver normal and
neoplastic brain tissue well included
process specificity specificity and
sensitivity for each target included in
the time
you
so after showing how we apply the midi
technology in the field of council a
second part of our webinar will focus on
how to design and optimize a mini panel
for cancer research in order to
construct the design nari panel the
following workflow that I will display
on the next slide the the following
workflow or the initial quality control
procedures for each region is routinely
carry out in our lab the analytic
validation is carried out on human
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
material antibody purity is evaluated
before colonization by SDS page in the
vision condition in order to make sure
that the antibody does not contain any
carriers that interfere with the method
combination
after the sexual metal labeling holidays
are tested anti-treaty by single X
chromosome a guided IC and subsequently
mine by living on the same tissue new
clone are tested before and after met
accommodation to ensure that metal label
of the antibodies does not interfere
with their target specificity for each
metal community antibody the working
title is determined by nu D as the title
that yielded maximal separation between
signal and noise across different
occupation tissue processing and stain
and quantitative analysis are carry out
as described in our recent publication
himself moving forward after the initial
quality control procedure we can proceed
we constructed the metal labeled
antibody panel and how does this is done
we first assigned a couple metal to the
antigen such that the proposed markers
will accurately define each population
of interest if a consideration should be
taken to account during this step first
we need to choose the right combination
of metal antigen according to the nature
of the tissue study meaning that if you
are characterizing the immunity reaching
the Kazakh clingfilm you would want to
convey to 345 with the business metal to
avoid potential + /p level and here is
reported for your convenience the table
summarizing the relative sensitivity
between elemental metal tags and just to
give you a brief explanation you know
the person made the effective
sensitivity for detecting metal tag
antibody tissue our group same serial
section of tonsils with 16 different
elemental metal isotope kanuda relative
to an identical monoclonal cd45 antibody
from each section the 100 micron field
of view was imaged by medical following
imaging bringing tissue was resolved and
ran into
chances elementa icp-ms from which
elemental isotope concentration was
extracted and calculated sensitivity was
calculating by comparison the total
number of metal atoms the 30 millimeters
and the absolute solution quantification
and finally values was normalized to the
tissue area used for both measurement as
you can see from this figure the
sensitivity of the neuticals
exceeded by up to 37 fold death of the
most sensitive element 159 TV reported
using a muscle geometry which is
represented by the last histogram bar
on the next slide we need to be our eyes
lighting between you to remember the
certain megohm like proceed PR and ND
press civilian and medium may result in
plastic inch below the due to the
oxidation we can which can be easily
avoided by assign the right antigen in
this channel next type
to construct a successfully in a repair
is the tissue microwave design or
chainmail design texting appropriate
issues set to determine analytic
sensitivity and specific specifically
for each target introducing the panel is
part of our new lead panel validation
based on the target
you wished into using the time you will
have to design a different DNA
containing both negative and positive
tissue control
let's now provide an example I plan to
clutter eyes using a 40 Market panel
linearly filtration breast carcinoma
tissue with a specific focus on the
myeloid component such as the mythic
cells and macrophages for these peoples
of your design DNA containing the
following tissue type tonsil placenta
liver and spleen in order to optimize
and validate the desired Navy panel I
would also whenever possible include
healthy brain tissue as it represents an
optimal negative control for many links
oil markets and other a spur to take
into account when selecting appropriate
issue types to validate the design a
lieutenant is that often during chronic
inflammation like council receptors can
be upregulated or downregulated
therefore I would strongly recommend to
include in your DNA design also normal
breast and breast carcinoma specimen in
order to see first how certain mark and
behavior inflammation in fact second how
to adjust your titration according to
the tissue entered which in this example
would be breast carcinoma
while the TNA is designed as you can see
on the next slide the overall district
quality will be evaluated on a similar
in methoxy and asian section or a
Chinese section under light microscope
this initial section representing our
reference standard for histological
examination should be followed by tips
of cereal section on may be slide or go
slide as you can see on the next edge
line in order to generate six title of
the panel
the working title is determined as the
title that is maximum separation between
signal and noise across issue as you can
see the 50 in the bottom of this video
this approach will help to assess the
specificity and sensitivity for each
target with regard to its cellular
localization subcellular localization
the four million members and
hyperplastic as well as cost rational
protein across different tissue type
respective same pattern should be noted
for reaction comprising of male plastic
and no no plastic issue control when a
negative tissue control is unavailable
appropriate otherwise original enters
with both positive and negative areas
will be evaluated once the antibody
cocktail is generated a single core of
council and you can see on the next
slide
a single column counsel included in the
same slide of the sample will be stained
during each experiment and run for
longitudinal standardization data
emerging from the internal control will
be examined for change in signal
intensities of the possible populations
in parallel HTML section will be stained
with the sample of interest in cork in
order to provide service quality control
of XE performance or other potential you
should emerge during the extreme
to conclude
the evaluation criteria for internal
panel is perform by comparing the middle
scope expression pattern to the
conventional single X chromosome I
cannot see an example on how the
comparison of selecting markets carry
out is reported in our recent
publication so while we show how the
expression partition for each market
analyzed was equivalent in both single
plugs congenic ellipses and maybe
samples as you can see from this video
the summer ecology and cellular
localization of the Sun matter is
comparable between the two as say for
example cd20 was primarily found in the
germinal Center where b-cells are the
predominant population while simply and
cd4 primarily result in the inter
follicular Zone which is populated with
itself as a sub cellular localization of
the transcriptional factor cases the
cell was prevalent nuclear whereas
before and cd20 localized in the
membrane as expected to conclude in
combination with visual comparison
between IFC and movies we also evaluate
the course pressure of protein on the
same cell there is unknown biological
property of the market or not
significant co-expression due to
expression in a different compartment of
the cell or on a different cell type